I think in order to understand a culture
you should learn the language and you
should eat the food and I think these
Chinese restaurants around the world not
just in America but also in Canada
Mexico because this book American
Chinese restaurant that's edited by
myself and hiding Lou it's not just a
USA story it's a you know it's a Latin
America Sir Johnny's pressures are all
over Latin America right it's a huge
restaurant they have shaped and impacted
Peru Argentina Chile and these are not
in the discourse and so Alan the reason
why I also want to show at this book was
because every time I read as a academic
I would read these like stories of
racism on the Chinese you know
restaurant wars and you know they
weren't allowed the 1880 Chinese
Exclusion Act excluded Chinese people
from coming to us that's true and all
these things are right and I would read
these these things and they would
mention Chinese restaurants is the way
how the restaurant workers I'm sorry the
railroad workers after they were done
with the railroad they couldn't go back
to China so they started Chinese
restaurants and I thought that was
interesting story and definitely
interesting but I having been raised in
a Chinese restaurant knew that there are
so many other stories of positive
opportunities for these like poor
Chinese people but also interactions so
a lot of people don't understand that
Chinese restaurants are safe spaces for
lots of minorities so Jewish Americans
during Christmas time they go to Chinese
restaurants during their birthdays they
go to Chinese restaurants and so it is a
space open to another ethnic group that
you know lets them eat their food and
because it doesn't have that much dairy
and they're open on Christmas it becomes
it becomes part of their modernity right
and it's not in the history and I want
to write about one day is the fact that
african-americans were excluded in so
many spaces in America but not Chinese
restaurants and so you have a lot of
african-americans who just have these
stories of going to Chinese restaurants
such as my trainer in the Midwest and
having these like generational stories
and I think that those stories I mean
yes there were racism but those other
stories and like this massive
kind of like safe space like as you say
those are not really told in the
literature and that so that's why I
wanted to someone's opinion me
contradict yours where's my friend Alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we if what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Satya
we are still on site at the American
Anthropological Association Annual
Meeting in Vancouver British Columbia in
Canada this is our second partnership
with them we are now going to be talking
about American Chinese restaurants and
so much more we have dr. Jeni bond
joining us on the show hello hi Jenny hi
thanks for coming on the program
thank you for anybody me I'm really
excited to talk about your new book and
much more I want to start with some of
the questions that we love asking our
guests do you think that we're really
all one well Leslie White is a very
famous anthropology anthropology and he
talks about energy and how we all have
different energies right but we're all
part of the universe energy so to some
extent I do believe that we're all
interconnected and in terms of energy
yeah and I can send you positive energy
you can send me negative energy there's
like I think that we are all connected
energy I believe that when you come into
a room your energy before you comes room
will affect the room subtly and so I
believe that all of us have energy
wherever we go and people can feel it on
a subconscious level so much of what you
just said about energy is super present
from the initial moments of whatever you
call it the Big Bang or creation or all
that is or whatever you want to call it
source
until now and how this path of all
coming from one until now has deep roots
in interconnectedness the air that I
breathe in is the air phytoplankton in
trees breathe out I take a bite of an
apple it comes from the power of the Sun
and so the lack of children
understanding that feeling separate
rather than feeling interconnected would
you say that that those feelings of
separation like what in indigenous
tribes from around the world are trying
to remind modernity about would you say
that that's the root of many of our
issues I think there's many roots but
definitely the interconnectedness major
is something that is a definite root of
disconnected and I would definitely say
that our electronics is one of the
things like social media the addiction
to social media and also the diction to
our electronics is you know part of that
root of feeling you making you feel
disconnected I live in California with
Silicon Valley there's many people who
are spilling multiple million dollars
for you to stay on that app for as long
as possible and they're doing everything
they can to keep you on that computer on
your computer to like it all these
masterminds to make you feel so it's for
advertising to make more income for them
so that is I think one of the many roots
but definitely I would say like this new
kind of you know this new really huge
change for humans that we're constantly
connected in a way that makes us almost
disconnected is one of the roots so yes
very interesting yes yes I like how you
bring into the equation
especially on a x times scale visibility
here on the millions of years of human
evolution we're looking at just e very
very last 10 or so years of having these
devices around us and using them all the
time pulling at them 150 times a day the
business plans hours of our time the
business plans of the attention economy
being tied to advertising this is a very
also interesting thing you know being
able to query civilizations knowledge at
my finger
this is also very interesting so that
there's a I'm really excited for the
next wave of conscious evolution that
comes and builds the next ways that we
connect with devices because it will be
much more around the interconnectedness
and less so about a profiteering on
people's attention Jenny I'm curious
what are your thoughts about the overall
purpose of reality why are we here
that's a deep question I'm asking the
deep ones over here why are we here I
don't know if I can answer for everyone
on earth I can only answer for myself I
think I'm here for a purpose I have my
own motto and I don't know about other
people like why they're here they
probably have their own reasonings but
my model is to create culture to use my
privilege and power to help oppressed
populations 3 to create what I don't see
and for my last model is reveal hidden
stories and so that's how why I'm here
and that's a from living my life that's
my purpose other people I don't know
they have I'm sure they have their own
purposes let's go through those again
those were really good ok you want to
create culture ok culture yeah number
two use my privilege and power to help
oppressed populations yeah you use
privilege and power to help oppress pop
you we all have our we are both
privileged individuals in a Western
space so here where when we buy a cup of
coffee that same price is what 50% of
people around the world make in a day
right yeah and we're not the vet amis
coffee Pickers you're getting poisoned
and de noms you make that coffee bean to
send it Starbucks oh yes
that is something so that's what I can
do in my own little way because these
are our brothers and sisters around the
world that we want to help uplift these
this is us we are one and working and
feeling that rather than buying a third
car third house third boat watch
whatever
investing it into the art and
entrepreneurship and science and
spirituality of people around the world
to come up and be uplift and bring very
unique gifts forward I love that one
okay three was I was so great culture
use my public
was it create what I don't see so
sometimes I want to see things happen I
wanted and is maybe this is kind of goes
into the model minority myth for Asians
but if I don't see it I'll create it so
I believe I can create what I say so if
I say it I can create it and so how else
can you bring you unique gift to the
world if it's you know if it's not there
we have to manifest it see the next
world that we're going to build and then
build that yeah so I've been wanting to
be an anthropologist since I was eight
years old so since I was eight years old
I wanted to see the world I wanted to
see different cultures and because I
watch a lot of Star Trek and public
broadcasting and so it was just like
really fascinating and so I could see
those people creating culture doing
things revealing hidden story my last
one is revealing hitting stories right
and so particularly for PBS right I saw
a show where they the interviewer
interviewed a giant African tribe where
they're very tall and then he just drove
like you know I guess a hundred miles
away and it was a pygmy kind of shorter
tribe and how's this possible you know
my eight-year-old self is like oh my god
humans are so diverse and it's so
interesting and then this kind of goes
into my Star Trek love and that it's
really kind of anthropology show in a
way and that it really reveals a lot of
different cultures and kind of being
tolerant and of these cultures and how
they have lots to lots of value right
and so that's like within all these four
probably has something to do with more
like my sci-fi your ship yeah well those
are such four profound ones and I hope
that those that are watching can also
both relate to and resonate with some of
the ones that you mentioned because I
sure do and then also reflect on our own
purposes what is our unique
all here in the world and if we haven't
really established that yet the
importance of like writing it down and
really reflecting on it on a daily basis
with our unique gift is to bring to the
world so crucial let's dive in this this
was really interesting learning about
this about you you did another interview
and you sent it over to me and I was
reading it and when I was hearing about
this see you were born in Hong Kong and
then came here very young three months
three months in the u.s. the u.s.
America yes and then you grew up in
Bellevue
no noise near Chicago yes it's like over
our way yes okay suburbs suburbs
working-class suburb chefs and then um
you spent a lot of your time working in
the inner Chinese restaurant yes yes
uh-huh
interesting and so then this kind of
spurred part of at least a good chunk of
this American Chinese restaurants most
recently anthropological study that
you're doing of really this like how in
many ways Chinese diaspora come into
very interesting social communities
around things like these restaurants
which actually have you were telling me
almost 50,000 Chinese restaurants in the
u.s. more than McDonald's Burger King
and Wendy's combined that is
mind-blowing because we see those chain
restaurants everywhere but we don't
think about counting the B yeah the
Chinese and there's all these different
the provinces and China have unique
foods yeah and there's all this kind of
stuff yet over thirteen regional like
food cultures yes yeah this is so
interesting so take us to even in there
in the in the childhood what is it what
was it like being a part of that that
node in Bellevue when you were growing
up and then how it relates to what your
studies are today so a lot of it I think
back now but as a child I didn't
understand but as a child I you know I
worked in the restaurant I was six seven
eight and our customers were a primarily
working-class Anglos as well as African
Americans primarily African Americans
how are you doing this at six seven
eight yeah just take orders
because that's how you did it six seven
eight
taking problem yeah so I was a cultural
broker so my parents did speak English
and so I would translate for them right
and I would write the orders and it was
I didn't really I only realized now but
I would code-switch and I would I would
translate that culture to my parents who
you know cooked in the back and I could
understand how I had a change
differently to each population that I
served right so for african-americans I
was a certain way Anglo Americans just
like kind of things that you learn and
then of course I switched my my I'll
switch my kind of like my personality my
parents I'd have to be you know
thoughtful and very within the age of
the culture I think stiller to our
meaning you have to say you have to be
respectful yeah
of the family dynamic of your father has
to be you know the king right but it's a
strange way to grow up because I had to
translate for them so I in many cases my
father didn't speak English and so I had
it speak for him and do all these things
I'm not unlike a lot of immigrants
around the world who have to be
translators like you you're a translator
you're cultural broker and so I got that
word cultural broker yeah it's so
interesting that you were taking these
orders and you're like dealing with one
and it's not even one it wasn't just the
American melting pot you were dealing
with a bunch of cultures you're taking
their orders in English but a bunch of
different cultures and then you are
doing oh really
this interesting process for a young
kids especially to go through with the
neuroplasticity that they have their
ability to switch all of what you just
took in to then was it was it Mandarin
was Cantonese Cantonese Cantonese yeah
interesting so then you treat you yeah
disseminated that in Cantonese yeah and
then I went to Catholic school a
Catholic school has its own regime so I
would go to cal school every day and you
know we'd go to church in the beginning
a night and
it has his own cultural norms our
teachers were nuns and priests and so I
had to change again for that for that
environment yeah
yes you're switching between
environments like that at a young age
where different cultures a day and that
will really quickly open up a get an
understanding of cosmopolitan dynamics
openness in general trying to you learn
a lot more about other people and walks
of life gain more empathy and insight
into that well I see a phobia this types
of things I don't think I realized as a
child I decided I just switch likewise
just never we really met you just
changed like it's like yeah 20s 30s 35
like mid 30s you kind of realize these
most profound things that happen to you
when you were young that kind of shaped
and then you like call your mom and dad
or whatever you say like that called it
happen yes I'm like thinking you worked
so hard you can't instilled in us so
then so then there was a dynamic there
that was happening where it was kind of
like a central point to a Chinese
community in Bellevue is there's no
Chinese community there wasn't zero so I
was the only unicorn there yes in the
school as well the whole city's oh in
the whole school yeah and the whole city
as well in the city yes I had never seen
any more 10,000 yeah yeah people yeah
I've never seen anyone Asian and I was
you know later on seventeenth great yeah
yeah so then feeling I didn't realize
this right and so I identified with
african-americans because in the
Midwestern there's only two there's only
Anglo or african-american and so
cognitively I I kind of thought I was
african-american until first grade and I
said mom I wear black I'm black and
she's like no you're not black him house
she's like upset I'm like but I I know
I'm not like everyone else but she said
you know Cantonese but uh yeah but I
think this is a very common thing for
Chinese restaurants in America in that
you sort of you your your clients are
certain people and then how you do
navigate spaces and then you start
identifying the people who serve yeah
okay so then what was it that then made
this so now it kind of makes sense that
you had this upbringing that catalyzed a
lot of your interest in doing
anthropological research on the specific
thing but now with these findings I mean
this number is staggering in the first
place fifty thousand Chinese restaurants
they use that number staggering well all
over the world it's like one of the
number one restaurants it's not just
America it's all over the world there's
Chinese restaurants right every country
whereas like for example I probably only
recently became used to seeing like an
Ethiopian restaurant or something yeah
I'm Tsaritsyn the food is incredible but
it's much less common though wait right
yeah we're you know even me talking to
someone recently about like German or
Austrian food right and they were just
like well what does that taste like yeah
yeah yeah stuff like that yeah there's a
such a familiarity with Chinese food
over there is it such as a China's
spending billions of dollars to push
their hard cultural power around you
know trying to develop their language
schools all over the world but in a way
their poorest members from China they're
migrant around the world is you know by
surviving and sounding different Chinese
food is like kind of providing soft
cultural power in a way yeah even though
it's not directed by anybody it's but
it's a way of similar to Korean k-pop
like BTS that's like Korean social a
soft power so but that's kind of you
know planned a little bit but this is an
unplanned kind of just cultural
dissemination yeah this was also an
interesting point you you talked about
it like the relationship between food
and society yes I really like it phrased
that way well I think in order to
understand a culture you should learn
the language and you should eat the food
and I think these Chinese restaurants
around the world not just in America but
also in Canada Mexico because this book
American Chinese restaurant that's
edited by myself and Jaime Lou it's not
just a USA story it's a you know it's a
Latin American or Chinese dresser
all over Latin America right it's a huge
restaurant they have shaped and impacted
Peru Argentina Chile and these are not
in the discourse and so Alan the reason
why I also wanted to edit this book was
because every time I read as an academic
I would read these like stories of
racism on the Chinese restaurant tours
and you know they weren't allowed the
1880s you Chinese Exclusion Act that
excluded Chinese people from coming to
us that's true and all these things are
right and I would read these these
things and they would mention Chinese
restaurants is the way how the
restaurant workers I'm sorry the
railroad workers after they were done
with a railroad they couldn't go back to
China so they started Chinese
restaurants and I thought that was
interesting story and definitely
interesting but I having been raised in
a Chinese restaurant knew that there are
so many other stories of positive
opportunities for these like poor
Chinese people but also interactions so
a lot of people don't understand that
Chinese restaurants are safe spaces for
lots of minorities so Jewish Americans
during Christmas time they go to Chinese
restaurants during their birthdays they
go to Chinese restaurants and so it is a
space open to another ethnic group that
you know lets them eat their food and
because it doesn't have that much dairy
and they're open on Christmas it becomes
it becomes part of their modernity right
and it's not in the history and I want
to write about one day is the fact that
african-americans were excluded in so
many spaces in America but not Chinese
restaurants and so you have a lot of
african-americans who just have these
stories of going to Chinese restaurants
such as my Transocean in the Midwest and
having these like generational stories
and I think that those stories I mean
yes there were racism but those other
stories I'd like this massive kind of
like safe space like as you say those
are not really told in the literature
and that's so that's why I wanted to
this book 20 chapters sounds like a lot
of times yeah whoa so that's a really
interesting nuance and actually a point
that again like you're describing is not
necessarily highlighted especially in
terms of like mainstream news if so few
people are going to want to talk about
this the space for
the Chinese restaurant for Jewish people
for african-americans to be able to come
and enjoy at times when maybe they
couldn't otherwise and that's really
nice and then that's probably only one
of so many other examples of oh yeah so
give us these other examples well in
Latin America right the it's oh there's
lots of people with a high population
but it's also a working class population
and so particularly in Chile and Peru
and different spaces they actually
provide a cheap affordable and delicious
food source for masses of people right
and so that is something often not
talked about how and the price point of
Chinese food is actually not expensive
right I mean there's higher ones that
having Lee talks about in PF Changs it's
like a nicer brand and there's like all
these very high high restaurants in Hong
Kong and Shanghai but in Latin America
all over are like in nine states like in
Canada are inexpensive relatively right
and others and that provides a lot of
people food at a great entertaining
price low price and particularly for
students and they'll work and that's
math it's kind of like ramen it's like
top you know cup of noodles it's like it
masa feeds a lot of people and that's
what it's done it's it's really done and
it's it's kind of giving it a taste of
you know globalization to people in I
guess the Caribbean islands you know
Chinese food and of course Africa
another way there's a lot of Chinese
restaurant now in Africa they're you
know soft power of I don't think it's
intentional but you know they're
surviving in these different African
countries Chinese restaurants yeah whoa
so another part of this is these more on
the end of more affordable prices that
also feed quite a lot so you can have
the collegiate students or you can have
people that gain the ability for you
know $10 an entree US dollars here in
the states that were an entree can maybe
even share that amongst weren't you
people are half half of it out
later or whatever and get a taste of the
cuisine as well yeah as an interesting
point you kind of a globalization they
feel that they're experiencing another
culture yeah different thing yet another
part of this is the actual community
that's formed around the Chinese
restaurant itself in terms of the
dynamics of if this is like like in this
example maybe in like for your mom and
dad for them starting their restaurant
there were no really other Chinese
people in Bellevue yet it's interesting
to think about these other pockets where
the restaurant that Chinese restaurant
actually maybe became like a hub in
sometimes for other families to come
yeah definitely nice families and you
guys could meet and like get to know
each other that we didn't have the
experience but I've read about those
people
my cousins lived another state Missouri
we rarely saw them but when we saw them
they also own a nice restaurant I think
it can be a hub for I've read you know
for other Chinese I did experience at
myself but yes a lot of Chinese
restaurants have double menus and so a
double menu is there's a rest there's a
menu for anglo-americans which would be
like orange chicken broccoli and beef
and these are things that are not found
in China I was differences big yeah this
is very Americanized yeah we don't have
a like Beijing cow yeah like I love that
Beijing roast duck
we don't okay or we don't like really
and I've never eaten at a Chinese
restaurant in the US where it's been
like you know Beijing roast duck is on
the you know I mean what's a pan Express
I see do they have no no no that's a
good chain yeah yeah yeah but no it's
super like those ones you were just
listing was that and I love like the
more authentic life
yeah like tripe was another one the cow
stomach was another one with the peanut
sauce on it I was like a bunch of
interesting varieties that are totally
not Oh so that would be on the Chinese
menu Oh the W and so
American menu with would be orange
chicken right and there's no orange
chicken China
that's invention in America and fortune
cookies there's no fortune cookies in
China they're not one and that one in
China this they would Jennifer Lee he
wrote a great book on that great
wonderful TED talk which talks about
chop suey
a chop Suey's is big a chop suey just
literally means leftovers right and so
they're serving this thing to survive in
America called chop suey
it's called leftovers right and so
that's a thing chop suey means leftovers
it doesn't leftovers so you say oh if
you go to China you're like can I have
some leftovers or like what
but there's so many Americans who love
chop suey right and they say oh can I
have chopped and I've noticed in Canada
they had this thing called Chinese pie
which is equivalent to just shepherd's
pie which is just potato on top but they
call it Chinese pie and it's not from
China potatoes are not from China
Chinese people don't really eat beef
because that's their number one worker
why do you want to eat your worker like
India you don't want your work so they
don't really serve beef and then so
there's no this Canadian Chinese pie is
not Chinese so it's yes that's the
double menu yes and broccoli has never
been grown ever in China
broccolis never been grown no no they
have their own broccoli they have
Chinese broccoli that's lost the long
stock so that in itself it's interesting
I think what at Chinatown was next to a
little Illinois at one point in New York
so maybe that I don't know the origin
but something must have happened where
they started this because Chinese food
in America is used with American
ingredients right so it's America
ingredients right Americans love fried
and crispy things with lots of sugar on
it and so those are American palate
points right and then they love beef in
a huge huge quantity and then broccoli
so yeah those are American I know so
it's kinda like I'm kind of wondering if
you're gonna ask me about authenticity I
mean yeah this is where this
this is where this part of conversations
for sure heading it's interesting when
you're talking about designing for this
pallet well as much as you know loving
you know fried foods and having like
sugar like orange chicken basically
right yes it also kind of also kind of
like reminds me of like you know if you
ever maybe you're like fasted for you
know a couple hours or if not maybe even
quite a bit you have intermittently been
fasting and then you eat a vegetable of
some sort even like a carrot or a tomato
whatever you eat right you eat some sort
of us we even a spinach leaf it really
doesn't matter when you eat it your
palate is like so there's been a delay
with the fast though your palate almost
tastes this it tastes of sugar
you know the actual vegetable right it
tastes how sweet the carrot is or the
tomato it's a spinach leaf etc and
training our palates to respect that is
very important if we want to live
healthy on a day-by-day basis if we want
to live with a good lifespan as well and
a health span both of those things and
also just I mean you can really just
it's a good way to do this experiment is
to take something like you know a piece
of chocolate or something
and take that piece of after you eat the
first spinach leaf right you ain't that
you taste it all sweet that was then you
take the piece of chocolate you know put
that on your palate and try that and
then you're like wow that was so much
sweeter then if you go to the spinach
lis afterward any taste of spinach leaf
it doesn't taste sweet at all right so
it's because we have this PA this long
process of training our taste buds
towards these things that we can also
repattern our behaviors towards more
healthy decisions so I appreciate you
pointing that out because it also
hopefully enlightens us too too because
you know how do you feel after you eat a
plate of orange chicken versus how do
you feel when you have you know
more vegetable on your plate and and I
mean those are really interesting
comparisons but yeah so the authenticity
is also a big one because you know just
coming back from China and September I
loved the food we're in China edible
it's been lots of time in Beijing spent
time in Hangzhou oh wow it's got a
little bit of time of Shanghai loved it
loved it and interviewing professors at
Peking University and hung in Wesley
University in Hangzhou this was lots and
lots of fun and it was the the level of
immersion into Chinese culture at the
most like deepest roots root level of
the psyche of the philosophies of that
time selves very important instead of
seeing like the worst thing to do is
just to look at like mainstream news and
take some sort of a distorted image of
what a whole thousands of years of
culture actually is so that's probably a
big takeaway that I make but also just
like that actually speaks to
authenticity as well in terms of just
people themselves like you know I would
never just try and like like walk into
whatever even if it's a Chinese
restaurant or if it's any cultures
restaurant and just try and come in with
a image of what that restaurant is based
on mainstream media versus based on my
own experience ability to ask you
questions about who you are where you
come from what the culture is what you
love to do in life what your deepest
thoughts are about the nature of this
reality there's always a better way to
get to what I think are the roots of
people rather than what looks like
distorted images so if something I
talked to chef trapped in the book I
interviewed a chef Martin Yin and he we
talked about authenticity a lot and
because that's always the critique of
these Chinese wrestling around the world
that they're not authentic they're not
in China they're not they're kind of
these orange chicken
you know fortune cookie things made up
right but I think we both agree that
these places were places of survival and
so these
different communities this is what the
people wanted to eat they do not want to
eat cow tongue right or the stomachs
right so this is what they had to serve
in order to survive and and a lot of
times they didn't work they didn't get
paid or get like first I was never my
sister and I we're never paid right we
just work for herds all the time they
and my my mother was also working there
she also did get paid and so you're
doing this to survive and so that is
what your clientele wants and so that's
what you have and and I respect my
parents are doing this they didn't have
a culinary background they just went
into the Midwest and open a restaurant
and so but it enabled us to survive I
have a PhD all my cousins who have they
all have doctor ISM and upper degrees
and all of our family members are well
some of them were Chinese restaurant
workers and owners and so enabled us to
survive into the next turn next
generation yes do you see other sorts of
macro trends around the way that during
diasporic moments that families create
restaurants what they know they know
their food so they make the restaurant
so they can reuse it as a mechanism of
survival and also sharing culture yeah
is that like a frequent macro I think so
it's like it's kind of I think Jennifer
Lee talks about it Chinese food it's
like a free app that everyone can get
and and it's spread like Linux it's like
everywhere I mean over 50,000 that's a
lot of restaurants right and so that's
something I think being Chinese
that's your cultural right you have your
culture right to your food and so that's
something you know right you know your
language your food and that's something
that you could I don't want call it so
but it's something that you can use to
survive and I think that's yeah so I'm
glad you asked that question yeah it is
definitely a macro trend that people I
don't understand but I was gonna say
that a lot of these Chinese people's
it's a way of coming home to the same
imagine of homeland because to be honest
all these Chinese people around the
world with global diaspora
so if we're saying 60 to 70% of the
earth is Asian let's say 20 almost 23
percent the worth is Chinese or it's
almost 1 in 4 people or at least you
know 20% when you eat Chinese food you
can eat an imagined homeland right so
there's like some energy level of taste
that you can you know your grandmother
ate those you know Armenian up items and
then she loved it and then your father
ain't you ain't it so you you feel this
like connection and I think that yes I
definitely agree it's like some sort of
macro spreading but with kind of a
homeland feel yes this is again in the
ability of the person that not only yeah
goes and has the moment of wanting to
provide what their culture can bring to
the area that they move to but also the
person that comes from that local area
to experience that culture and their
food you made this clear at the very
beginning too is that you have you learn
a bit of the language learn a bit of the
food ask good questions don't just come
to this restaurant without inquiry into
the deeper levels of the roots of the
people and the culture and wanting to
learn because it's a missed opportunity
to learn yeah and if we can instill that
curiosity in children to want to learn
even at the level of just a restaurant
when they go and they learn about the
food and they learn about the culture
etc it'll make it so that the world
becomes more of that one community yeah
I also I also want I also want to ask
you this question because given the
amount of I don't know if there's been
study into this given the amount that
small medium-sized businesses around the
world are yes some are coming up but
most of them are going away due to the
increased amount of massive corporations
taking stock in their ability to deliver
groceries deliver restaurant food
soon it's already being tested to be
done by autonomous cars and robots and
drones and all different types of
delivery mechanisms like that given that
do you foresee something also occurring
or hasn't there been any study with that
number of fifty thousand restaurants
potentially and that's just in the US
but around the world slowly potentially
declining and needing to find other work
and all this other kind of stuff I would
say absolutely not for Chinese food
number one Chinese food the price point
you can't reproduce it for that price
point with a machine right the how
Chinese Russians work is a lot of unpaid
labor right and a lot of and it's down
the line how to get their items and it's
all how do they if there's unpaid labor
how do those people live if they're
unpaid
well like family yeah they're family
like I I wasn't paid but the only family
because then because then the father
although you're on paid to pace for the
rent and right right yeah that kind of
stuff so I I don't see a machine because
if we you actually really paid people
what they work right the the prices for
a Chinese restaurant those items of corn
even orange chicken would be triple the
price right even in reproducing it in a
in a form that is mass-produced it will
never be the same I don't say quality
but that I don't want the authenticity
but that traditional recipe cannot be
reproduced right what you had in Beijing
cannot be reproduced in a mass Swanston
right or something you know and I just
don't see it happening because
particularly I think just Chinese people
are very hardworking as all people are
but they're very they will go they will
they I don't see it I think that no
machine can reproduce a traditional
there's like you know over 1200 cultures
in China they can cannot I don't see I
don't see it yeah
and I do which is interesting
interesting ok I see nothing I see
nothing the the area of what human
expertise has advantage over
ai and automation robotics that area is
very rapidly decreasing and I I do
foresee some people being able to like
you know grapple on for like the last
couple of like these decades that are
that it's coming
but even then I like it's pretty clear
to me that within a hundred years the
definition of like work is gonna be so
much different there's going to be oh
yeah there's gonna be a lot more one
could say like art or clay or that kind
of and this is in the most brightest
possible future there's lots of other
ranchers where there's you know
bifurcation based on socioeconomic
status of people the ones that owned the
AI and the automation the ones that
don't
and so there's got to be a heart centric
consciousness evolution that we focus on
where we uplift all of us and we
distribute the fruits of the emerging
technologies so that way everyone has
their ability to bring unique gifts
forth live a prosperous peaceful dignity
oriented and driven life and hopefully
have AI robotics automation just augment
for now until we then decide what is the
next evolutionary step after that which
in many ways could be what the what
humanity is a biological bootloader for
that next step of a digital style super
intelligence I hope you're right in that
we're all uplifted we are everyone yeah
it gets the fruits of AI yeah yes this
paramount yes I want to ask you this to
Jenny so um you have a passion for
helping first-generation college
students with their barriers and bridges
to college success specifically
Southeast Asian American and you were
teaching me about this this is really
really important given so much of people
moving like diaspora moving
across the planet and then trying to
seek a being able to actually bring
their unique gifts forth there are
barriers there are challenges to that
obstacles to overcome how have you seen
that process and been able to catalyze
assistance with that and help as I
mentioned I was a I was a Chinese little
8 year old cultural broker like you and
and so even one could argue a professor
as a cultural broker and so one of the
things I realized being asian-american a
type of tribe and or I don't know cuz I
guess I could be part of the human tribe
whereas 70 percent of humans or Asian or
the heat all humans you know 100% but
Asian Americans in particular I don't
know the Canadian situation but Asian
Americans in America are called the
model minority and they're called the
model minority because on aggregate they
have the highest graduate graduation
rates in college over fifty five percent
right so 55% of all Asian Americans have
a college degree and within that you
have like South Indians and Taiwanese
Americans and have an 80% graduation
rate with additional graduate degrees
like PhDs
doctors lawyers etc and so and also as
aggregates Asian Americans have the
highest income in terms of making over
60,000 70,000 a year which is quite a
lot in comparison to the average
American right so if you look at that
number you think Oh Asian Americans
they're the model minority they're doing
wonderful doing great right but when you
just get the numbers you actually see
that it's it's actually not correct not
true at all because number one
asian-americans a lot of them don't
speak English and they don't fill out
these census forms Asian Americans live
in multi Multi family households so if
seventeen people are making 2,000 a year
that's still gonna show up more than you
know one person with a nuclear family
right and of course a lot of those
people will not even report their income
right and so the numbers are incorrect
but in particular if you look at
Southeast Asians the Hmong them yen the
camus Cambodians Filipinos vet amis and
also low-income Chinese Japanese vetting
these people Americans they actually are
in
high poverty rates where 70% of them
report having a traumatic food or
poverty a written situation where they
could not they cannot you know help
themselves if they had a big issue right
and so particular Southeast Asians they
have one of the lowest graduation rate
with around 11 to 14 which is much lower
than the American national average this
is an important breakdown it takes
something that's viewed as a like you
said a model minority group and it
breaks it down and there are some
incredible practices that happen people
coming over with motivation and
determination and perseverance and grit
to get to actualize those gifts and want
to so there's some great things there
but when you do you know open that up
double-click in look at the breakdowns
there's some serious issues that have
happened with pop with specific people's
as diaspore coming to other parts of the
world where there is many of the time to
ask first comes from some sort of
violence or war or you know these yeah
yes genocides Janice Isaac um and then
the trauma is there from through family
lineages and then we're carrying that
trauma with us that needs to be healed
and we need to evolve and grow through
that and heal it and yes otherwise we
have
we have a with this we have this feeling
that comes when we encounter humans
where there's just something that is um
it's it's not whole it's not oh it's not
full hearted there's still something
there and and but then there's all this
like closed off from this with the
process of trying to heal it it's got to
be the right person at the right time
with the right circumstance all this
type of stuff so how do we catalyze
environments as frequently as we see
Chinese restaurants why don't we have
holistic healing centers that would be
great that I would love that that's a
social fabric I want to build you know
that's what we do that that's what we
want
are you wonderful for you to build that
why is we we will do it because why is
it that on the streets there are so many
options for food but so little places
for our emotions mm-hmm it's a disaster
that that's like that our emotions have
taken the most absolute backseat place
in the economic machinery now instead of
being able to talk with someone about
the true most visceral feelings that my
deep depths of my psyche now I like you
know and this is a trusted person now
I'm concerned but but when I you know
pay a therapist to try and like make
sure that they're not like self dealing
when they also want to prescribe me a
pharmaceutical and there's all this type
of you know indigenous people are trying
to wake up wake up
heal heal they're a process of healing
that we've been doing for millions of
years and that can be leveraged for
making it so that these breakdowns of
minority groups that you're talking
about that aren't as this don't have
60,000 plus dollar a year salaries that
they themselves can actually heal and
then can achieve their unique gifts that
they can bring to the world
I'm really happy that you bring that up
as well that's a really interesting
point so American Chinese restaurants
society culture and consumption is out
yes it's available the links in the bio
below it's an on Amazon Walmart but
Amazon is probably the easiest place to
get it link in the bio balut Jenny I
want to ask you another question one
more okay what do you think is most
beautiful
what a lovely last question hmm what
you've been asking a lot of these what
is the most so what uh what is the most
beautiful mmm so many things are
beautiful
well I I think that things in nature are
very beautiful I don't know but the most
again like what is the most right I
think nature is very beautiful being
nature things that all around me are in
a forest those are truly beautiful
places like Yosemite where I lived very
close to are very beautiful so those are
beautiful things and you feel like the
forest can kill you it's been there for
thousands of years and I think those are
very beautiful and then if you're with
your family in the forest and I you're
also going to feel even more beautiful
so I I really like nature and those I
think that area nature with your family
I think those are beautiful moments yeah
we highly recommend people to visit
Vancouver as well British Columbia I
mean oh like looking across towards
North Vancouver here it's beautiful
the mountains and the ocean and the
trees I mean it all speaks it all speaks
it communicates the energy it tells you
that you're not alone that you're
actually part of thousands of years and
you know your problem might be big to
you now but I'm a tree and I'm 100 years
old yeah and it's also deeply
interconnected and just remember to
embody that interconnection and
unconditional love
deep presence yeah this is such a great
interview thank you thank you thank you
know the program thanks for having me
you're super welcome thanks for all your
great work thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear our thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking on all of the cool things that
Jenny was teaching this lesson on your
thoughts check out the links in the
Bible Oh to Jenny's work also check out
the links in the Bible at American
Chinese restaurants you can use the code
as well in the bio below check that out
and also check out the links in the bio
blow to the American Anthropological
Association and support
than support their incredible annual
meeting and support simulation so we
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to great places like triple A's
annual meeting and conducting these epic
partnership interviews you can find us
on PayPal patreon cryptocurrency all
those links are in the bio below and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world you love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon that's a wrap okay
thank you so much
[Music]